today on the Matt Walsh show a lot to
discuss first we are going to talk about
the media's love affair with Governor
Andrew Cuomo in New York he's being
painted as the hero of the pandemic but
the reality is much closer to the
opposite and we'll talk about why also
some girls in Connecticut heroic I think
heroic girls are suing to prevent boys
from competing in girls sports but the
judge presiding over the case has
instructed the lawyers of the girls that
they must refer to biological boys in
women's sports as female which of course
destroys the entire case is impossible
for the girls to make their case if they
have to pretend in the courtroom that
the boys are female so we'll talk about
that insanity and in our daily
cancellation I will cancel a New York
Times writer who thinks that mothers
should be getting paid to be mothers for
all the work they do in the house and
I'll discuss that and explain why that
doesn't work at all it makes no sense
but starting with this the media has
smothered New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
with fawning praise from the beginning
of this crisis all the way to now the
downpour of adulation has not has not -
hasn't has not led up at any point and
they're you know still sagging even now
that he's been brilliant he's a great
leader he may be he should be the
candidate instead of Joe Biden which
that part they're probably right about
but then again I could pull a crusty old
sponge from under my sink and that would
make a better candidate than Joe Biden
at this point any case you can trash
that with the scorn heaped on take
somebody like Florida Governor Ron de
santis who we are told is reckless and
dangerous and imbecilic and all of these
other things but you can't help but
notice a key difference between these
two governors that may explain the
varied reception they have received and
that difference of course is the letter
next to their name and I don't think
it's probably not a coincidence actually
that they call me crazy but the media
has discovered that all of the
governor's who are doing a great job
happen to be Democrat the governors who
are doing a terrible job happened to be
a Republican but there is another
difference especially between the
governor of New York and the governor of
Florida and this is one that the media
pretends not to notice in hopes that you
also will not notice and that is this
Governor Cuomo has done the worst job of
containing the outbreak in his state
over 20,000 people dead while Governor
De Santis has been among the best fewer
than 2,000 dead with a population
slightly larger than New York State so
this appears to be the general pattern
right the governors who have presided
over the worst outbreaks are hailed as
heroes and we're told that everything
they're doing is right and correct and
we should model ourselves after it while
the governors who have been most
successful in controlling the spread are
cast as villains and nowhere is this
upside-down approach more evident than
with Governor Cuomo who is the
coronavirus champion we're told and yet
he's managed to get everything wrong
every step of the way now granted he has
faced a greater challenge than any other
governor you might argue because his
state happens to cape contain a city
with with with 26,000 people packed into
every square mile now that's gonna make
it a lot more difficult it also granted
that many of his missed steps are the
same missteps that many other governors
and elected officials have made it's
very clear now that locking everybody in
their homes and driving a knife directly
into the heart of the economy and and
embracing a Great Depression on purpose
in order to fight a virus was a very bad
strategy and one that may in the end
take more lives than it saves
Cuomo doesn't then deserve unique blame
for the disaster in that way I mean he
deserves a lot of the same blame that a
lot of other people deserve but he also
doesn't deserve unique praise which is
what he's getting at best he has been
just as incompetent as everybody else
that's the best thing you could say
about him and I think even that is being
too generous
Cuomo not only kept the subway system
open despite it being a known vector for
the illness but he apparently didn't
think that he should even give it a
thorough cleaning until this week we
played the video last week or this past
week I should say this past week we
played the video of they shut down
overnight service of the the subway and
they brought all these people in and
have them in hazmat suits to clean the
subway system it's the first time they
had done that since this started two
months ago but this is the kind
of decision-making we get from cuomo
worse though cuomo as i have been
talking about and i think this is i
think this is the story of the
coronavirus this right here is the story
that andrew cuomo not just him other
governors too forced nursing homes to
take in coronavirus patients which is
which is really the equivalent of
starting a campfire on a windy day in a
forest full of dead wood during wildfire
season I mean it is that reckless in
fact further record here is the March
25th governor cuomo handed down his
order commanding nursing homes to take
in Cova 19 patients and here's the the
order not gonna read the whole thing but
it says no resident shall be denied
readmission or admission to the NH
nursing home solely based on a confirmed
or suspected diagnosis of covin 19 NHS
are prohibited from requiring a
hospitalized resident who has determined
medically stable to be tested for cover
19 prior to admission or readmission did
you get that it's not just that they
were forced to take in Cova 19 patients
but the the nursing homes weren't even
allowed to require testing before
bringing the people in
now it has been well known from the
beginning that nursing homes are
particularly vulnerable to outbreaks and
their residents are most at risk of
fatal complications from the illness
nearly 5000 residents have died nursing
home residents have died from chrono
virus in New York alone and that's just
what we know about they added another
1,700 deaths last week that they hadn't
told us about in New York so are there
are there more deaths they haven't told
us but I think probably so in many other
states across the country well over half
of all fatalities have happened in
nursing homes that's why I say this is
the story right here of the corona virus
it's it's this it's what's happening in
nursing homes and what's happening is a
travesty and a tragedy and an outrage a
moral outrage because our elected
officials tasked with protecting these
people have failed and protecting them
should have been pretty easy to do
because they are contained in isolated
areas already in a in a medical or at
least semi medical environment so it
shouldn't be that hard to protect them
yet our elected officials failed
miserably they just fail they took
active steps to put these people in
harm's way and thousands upon thousands
of people died as a direct result of
that Cuomo's decision to forcibly
introduce the infection into these
facilities while also refusing to
provide protective gear because he said
quote that's not our job he was asked
about should we should we should you
shouldn't you at least send protective
gear if you're gonna send the Cova 19
patients in the nursing homes and he
said that's not my job I don't have to
do that that decision all of this
together can be directly blamed for many
deaths
how many who knows thousands the nursing
home mandate is a is a breathtaking
scandal in and of itself but you're not
gonna hear much about it on the news
because the news media has already
settled on its Cuomo the you know their
narrative is Cuomo the the corona
conqueror and you especially won't hear
about it on CNN a news network that has
enlisted Cuomo's admiring younger
brother to conduct its interviews with
the governor you know in the middle of
all this you've got a governor in his
state spit worse
than anybody else's he has made some to
put it mildly extremely controversial
decisions in the midst of this and CNN
which is supposed to be a news
organization when they want to bring him
on to talk to him about it they have his
younger brother interview him and these
segments of course receive fawning
approval to from the media the media
loves it but something tells me I mean I
imagine if if you think about the the
reception that these Cuomo V Cuomo chat
sessions get and people talk about how
great they are and cute and wonderful
something tells me that the people
impressed by that would not be nearly as
impressed if Fox hired let's say Don jr.
to do cutesy little interviews with his
father about the corona virus or about
anything else in fact so look as I said
obviously we cannot blame Cuomo for
every death in his state but we can ask
whether there is any good reason to
praise his performance I see compelling
evidence that his leadership has been a
huge failure where is the evidence that
has been a smashing success I don't see
that evidence maybe a different way of
phrasing this question is if Cuomo's
leadership during this crisis has not
been a failure what exactly would
failure look like if not like this a lot
more to say about this in in just a
second couple other points about all
this but before we do let me tell you
about our very good friends at Rock Auto
if you're looking for car parts if
you're if you're looking for great
selection and great prices then Rock
Auto is the best website that there is
for it I mean period hands-down so
simple that's why I'm always telling you
by rockauto.com because I really believe
in it I use it all the time myself
rockauto.com
is so much easier than walking into a
store dealing with all the questions not
finding what you need paying higher
prices cut out the middleman cut out the
trip to the store especially these days
and just go to rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear you know so they're not
going to charge you more because I think
they can get more out of it they're
gonna they're gonna charge as low as
they possibly can rockauto.com is a
family business which I love serving all
parts customers online for twenty years
ago to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts for hundreds of manufacturers
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck right
walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so that they know that we sent you
okay a couple of addendums here a couple
of by the ways first this mandate with
the nursing homes was finally reversed
just a few days ago but the reversal
itself makes the original mandate seen
even worse so here's the daily wires
reported says on sunday cuomo reassured
new yorkers that the state would no
longer send coronavirus patients to
nursing home facilities according to
reporters AK fink quote reversing his
march 25th directive forcing nursing
homes to readmit residents who were
treated at a hospital for cover 19 those
residents could only come back if they
test negative for the virus for ABC News
Cuomo said now we're just not going to
send a person who is positive to a
nursing home after a hospital visit he
said such patients would be accommodated
elsewhere suggesting that could be
directed to sites originally set up as
temporary hospitals what do you know you
think I mean in New York you had all
this extra you had whole you had ships
coming in you temporary field hospital
to me all this stuff all this extra
space most of it wasn't used so maybe
use some of that space rather than
sending kovin infected people into
nursing homes so they can infect hunches
of other people and then a bunch people
will die you know how about that now
coma also released a new set of nursing
home regulations telling Twitter that
quote all nursing home staff must now be
tested for kovat twice a week this role
is rule is not optional it's it's
mandatory
he said quote this virus uses nursing
homes they are ground zero they're the
vulnerable population in the vulnerable
location okay so the nursing homes are
Ground Zero the virus uses nursing homes
we've known this from the beginning so
why did you send people why did you
create more ground zeroes if you know
the virus uses nursing homes which we
have known
since early March if not earlier why did
you send the virus into nursing homes to
be used another note you know other
states have done this as I mentioned
California New Jersey Pennsylvania they
have all sent kovat infected elderly
people into nursing homes and thousands
upon thousands of deaths can be traced
back to these mandates the point is for
all this talk about killing grandma's
you know if you go to a park if you go
to the beach
we're told that what you're gonna hear
from from from the pro lockdown camp is
that you're killing grandma well no no
that doesn't kill grandma okay you go to
a park of the beach the virus probably
isn't gonna be spread anyway but even if
it is if grandma's not at the beach
she's not gonna get it okay if she's
staying isolated in her home she's not
gonna get it doesn't matter what you do
okay I mean you could go to the beach
and be coughing directly in people's
faces
please don't but you're only gonna give
it to Grandma of grandmas there or if
someone else gets it and then goes and
visits grandma but you know it's very
easy to not it we can isolate grandma if
grandma wants to be isolated she can be
isolated now if if grandma decides that
she doesn't want to be isolated I think
there are a lot of grandmas who are
saying yeah including my own parents by
the way who are who are grandmas and
grandpas you know like I don't know 20
times over by now
and what they're saying and I've heard
this from a lot of older people is
basically you know it's not like they're
suicidal they don't have a death death
wish but at the same time first of all
you don't need to shut down the whole
economy for our sake you don't need to
create a Great Depression for our sake
okay we don't want our children and
grandchildren to be destitute to keep us
safe and also what I'm hearing from from
from older people is you know I I don't
have a it's not like I got 50 years left
on earth I want to go live my life and
when I see my family I want to do things
I don't I don't want to hide in my house
for the next two years waiting for a
vaccine so the point is
grandma might make the decision might
say I want to go out I want to go to the
beach I think it's a very low risk going
to the beach even for Grandma I think
she'll probably be fine but regardless
she's an adult she makes that decision
okay and she and she should be able to
make that decision and take the
relatively moderate risk the all again
the only way that you as an individual
put grandma on harm's way is if she
chooses to go out and about if she
isolates in her home she's fine
but if you want to know something that
really did kill grandma's you want to
talk about who the real grandma killers
are here it is the grandma killers they
are not sitting on a park bench they're
not they're not in you know the Sun Sun
Tanning at the beach they are sitting in
governor's mansions passing down edicts
and mandates requiring that nursing
homes accept covered infected people
they're the grandma killers who's the
grandma killer andrew Cuomo is a grandma
killer all right let's go to headlines
because there's a bunch of interesting
stories we got to talk about but before
we talk about any of that I got to tell
you about I'm very happy to tell you
about Bambi you know when running an
issue when running a business I should
say HR issues can kill you and
especially these days you know added
problems like that dealing with HR it's
very complicated time that can be you
know very difficult and it caused a lot
of extra problems and that's why it's so
important if you're running a business
you know you got to have a very good HR
department wrongful termination suits
minimum wage requirements labor
regulations all of that stuff you're
dealing with an HR manager salaries
aren't cheap by the way you know in the
average salary of talking $75,000 a year
a lot of companies don't have that kind
of money so Bambi spelled BA MBE e was
created specifically for small
businesses you can get a dedicated HR
manager you can craft HR policy you can
maintain your compliance all for just
$99 a month rather than $75,000 a year
we're talking $99 a month with Bambi you
can change HR from your biggest
liability to your big
strength just like that and you're
dedicated HR manager is available by
phone email real-time chat from
onboarding determinations that customize
your policies to fit your business this
is all about what you want to do okay
you're not fitting into their mold
they're fitting into your mold month to
month no hidden fees you can cancel
anytime
go to Bambi comm slash Walsh right now
to schedule your free HR audit that's
Bambi dot-com slash Walsh be am be my
let's be a MBE e.com slash Walsh okay
your headlines number one if you listen
to the show for a while or you've read
my pieces on The Daily wire then you
have heard plenty about the situation up
in Connecticut where a couple of mail
runners who claim to be girls have been
dominating the girls track and field
circled these quote-unquote transgender
girls ie boys would be mediocre sort of
middle of the pack runners if they were
competing against their own kind which
would be the boys if they were if they
were doing what they were supposed to be
doing and not cheating they would be you
know they wouldn't be running in the
States or even the regional
championships probably their times are
not impressive for boys but against the
girls they're almost unstoppable
fortunately some real girls some quite
brave real girls are fighting back and
are filing a lawsuit god bless them to
try to protect women's sports you know
because the adults mostly adults in this
country are too afraid too afraid to
fight back against this too afraid to be
calling being called a bigot if we're
gonna have women's sports if girls
sports are going to exist somebody's got
to stand up and do this and fight for it
and so it falls on these teenage girls
to do it I mean think about all the
parents across the country who have
their kids in in these sports and and
then the the grab their daughters in
these sports and then the boys start
invading and I think of all the parents
that just just tolerate it rather than
standing up and saying no this is not
gonna happen I mean banding together as
parents and saying we're not going to
allow this we're not going to have our
we are not going to put our kids our
girls our daughters in
sports to take a putt to be a part of
this spectacle this charade no parents
don't do that because they're afraid you
know they're more afraid of being called
a bigot than they are determined to
protect the dignity of their own and
safety of their own daughters so these
teenage girls though they've stepped up
they filed a lawsuit trying to bar boys
from competing in girls sports but now
the attorneys of the girls filing a
lawsuit are trying to get the judge
presiding over the case recused are
trying to get him to recuse himself and
the National Review explains why it says
during an April 16th conference call
Judge Robert Chet igni chastised the ADF
attorneys for referring to the male
athletes seeking to compete in the
women's division as males according to a
transcript of the call obtained by
national review this is what chigney
said damn reading now from the what this
is what the judge said to these lawyers
he said what I'm saying is you must
refer to them as transgender females
rather than as males again that's the
more accurate terminology and I think
that it fully protects your clients
legitimate interests referring to these
individuals as transgender females is
consistent with science common practice
and perhaps human decency to refer to
them as males period is not accurate
certainly not as accurate as I think
it's needlessly provocative I don't
think that you surrender any legitimate
interest or position if you refer to
them as transgender females that is what
the case is about this isn't a case
involving males who have decided that
they want to running girls events this
is a case about girls who say they that
transgender girls should not be allowed
to run girls events so going forward we
will not refer to the proposed
intervenors as males understood okay you
can see why they want the judge to
recuse himself because the whole point
of the lawsuit you idiot in a robe the
whole point you [ __ ] is the whole the
whole case the plaintiffs are making is
that the so-called trans girls are not
female that's the point
that's the
you're presiding over if they're female
then there's no case okay and if these
girls are in the lawyers are required to
pretend that boys are female then they
are not able to make their case they
have no language with which to make
their case the case is gone so this is
madness he says right there this isn't a
case involving males who've decided they
want to run in girls events that's
exactly what this case is
that's 100% what's going on here so the
judge presiding over the case is denying
what the case actually is he's already
issued his decision he said up there
females okay well if they're females
then there goes that but they're not
females okay they're not not by the
science not by common sense and not by
human decency because they deny common
sense to deny science to say things that
are manifestly untrue and on top of that
to force girls to participate in this
charade and to take their medals and
achievements away from them none of that
is consistent with human decency and the
incredible thing is yeah this is what
I'm always saying about this issue this
judge Roberts at igni I don't know
anything about him okay I don't know
anything about but he's a he's a judge I
know that so you know he's in so that
tells me he's an adult at least then
he's probably he's probably on the older
side as a judge so I could pretty much
guarantee that chittock knee has lived
most of his life knowing that boys are
boys and girls are girls most of his
life he is known and never questioned
the fact you know if I had talked to
Roberts at igni seven years ago and I
asked him you know if a person has a
penis is that a boy or a girl he would
have said he would have looked at me
very very in a very confusing what
confused way and then he would have said
that's a boy okay so he's lived his
whole life knowingness and then at a
certain point
he changed his mind along with a lot of
other people they decided that oh you
know what none no no never mind never
mind actually actually men can have
babies girls can have penises yeah you
know what it's like a it's like a you
know you could take the parts off swap
them switch them
people are like mr. Potato Head dolls
now you just take off the different
parts swap em out it doesn't matter it
makes no difference parts don't matter
biology doesn't matter chromosomes don't
matter DNA doesn't matter reproductive
organs don't matter I mean what does
matter then and then we go back to that
question I mean I still haven't got an
answer to that question what is a woman
then you tell me Robert should take me
what's it define define female forget
about to find the word woman okay it
should take me you say that these boys
with with XY chromosomes and and penises
you say that they are females okay
define the word female you big dummy
define it you can't I mean you can if
I'd asked you five years ago you could
have offered me a definition but you
know that's a definition that would
exclude these guys so give me the new
definition you've decided somehow live
in your whole life knowing the truth and
then all of a sudden you decided that
these definitions don't work anymore
what's the new definition and what was
the scientific discovery what was the
the the epiphany moment for you when you
realize it oh you know what actually men
can give birth when did that happen did
you read a scientific study of some kind
did you make a discovery in a laboratory
can you tell us about it no the point is
that your kidney and all the rest of
these people they are the word coward
doesn't even come close to describing
them and that's why I just have no
respect for this kind of cow I mean
cowards of this magnitude I just have no
respect for them at all nothing but
scorn and contempt can i heap upon them
you are such a coward that you have a
and in reality because you're afraid of
people yelling at you and calling you a
trans folk all right let's move on to
number two in fact we might revisit this
ight now that I now that I think about
it I could do a whole monologue maybe we
will revisit this in greater length
later in the week okay number two Justin
Trudeau who's increasingly looking like
a character from The Count of Monte
Cristo recently started a rather weird
initiative I can't quite figure this out
but watch this video from Trudeau
hey kids I know we're all going through
a difficult time right now and it's not
made any easier by the fact that you
have to do your homework around the
kitchen table I think parents across the
country are discovering a new
appreciation for the incredible work
that teachers do well as a teacher I
want to help if you've encountered
challenges or problems that are really
tough and you need a little extra help
with why don't you reach out by
responding to this message or using the
hashtag our friends and I will be happy
to try and help you out because after
all the way we're going to get through
this is by pulling together so the Prime
Minister of Canada wants to help your
kids do their homework why who knows and
and why would a child send a tweet to
the Prime Minister of Canada rather than
just like asking his parents or even
asking Google you know who knows if I
wanted to find something more sinister
in this I could you know that's sort of
my specialty anyway and and and here the
AAB it's rather obvious what the
potentially sinister element of it is
that you have the government trying to
step into your kitchen and perform the
basic duties duties and functions of a
parent you have them trying to breed
dependency of a child on the state
rather than on the parent so I could
interpret it that way and that may be
not totally off-base but really mostly I
think Trudeau is just kind of goofy and
that's what this is all about okay by
the way I did look up while that was
playing I looked up Roberts your
technique just like because I was
curious and it said he's I think 68
years old
so I'm guessing that well into his 60s
he was quite sure that men have penises
I am I'm guessing that yeah and I don't
know I could be wrong and I will eat my
words if I am but I'm thinking if I if I
look back through his opinions and
decisions and everything he said
publicly I'm not gonna find anything
from him certainly under the age of
sixty of him speculating that maybe
somebody with a penis can be a girl I'm
guessing that so and it's just that just
puts a and really you know I I'm ranting
and raving I'm calling him stupid in a
dummy and all this and you might think
well that's very insulting and mean
actually I think it's quite generous
quite generous because if you think this
I mean if you think that a boy is
actually you know can is a female you're
either a very very stupid person very
stupid or something else
talk about sinister or there's something
more sinister going on where you know
the truth but you're denying it
even as a judge and trying to force this
untruth this falsehood even on these
girls who are just trying to defend
their basic rights and that's that's
something a lot worse than stupidity
okay number three the AP issued some
recommendations a few days ago updating
us on the politically correct term for a
woman who sleeps with a married man and
here's what they said they said we now
say not to use the archaic and sexist
term mistress for a woman in a long-term
sexual relationship with and financially
supported by a man who was married to
someone else
instead use an alternative like
companion or lover on first reference
provide details later and here we see we
see how the goal of politically correct
language is always to obfuscate right
where the goal the goal of language
generally is to communicate meaning the
goal of politically correct language is
essentially the opposite because
normally we call a mistress a mistress
and not a companion or lover because
first of all companion and lover are
both positive terms and decent people
don't think of marital Affairs as
positive things and so we have a weave
different word for it but then also if
you call a mistress a lover or a
companion you're gonna have to say more
to explain what you mean and you're
going to have to constantly add
qualifications whereas the word mistress
gets the point across without all the
extra baggage and confusion and that's
why we have different words for
different things the idea is to get the
point across in the least confusing way
and so we say mistress we know what you
mean we say companion or lover I don't
know I there's a lot of really essential
information that is not included in that
phrase that now you're gonna have to
explain and every time the word comes up
you're gonna have to qualify it in a
certain way so that it doesn't get
confusing but yeah there's a P number
for Yahoo News reports a top scientist
who fell ill with Kobe 19 has said the
world will never return to normal unless
there's a corona virus vaccine Peter
Piot director of the London School of
Hygiene and Tropical Medicine spent the
week in the hospital after contracting
the virus in March the Belgian biologist
who led the joints the United Nations
program on hiv/aids said climbing the
flight of stairs to leave some bracelet
breathless and anyway he goes on to say
that a vaccine is needed for people to
live normally again my only point here
is that we're hearing this more and more
first of all this is a massive shifting
of the goal posts because before we were
told it was all about flattening the
curve we have done that now they're
saying never mind it's about waiting
until there's a vaccine but second this
is a matter of choice I mean there is no
requirement if you want to if we all
decided we wanted to get back to living
our lives normally we can live our lives
normally yes there is the added threat
of kovin 19 which which has just added
on to all the other threats that come
with living your life normally and
people are gonna die just like people
die every day regardless that doesn't
mean it's not sad doesn't mean we don't
take steps to mitigate it but just
living your life normally comes with
certain risks anyway and so we're going
to make the decision to start that and
to start living or not but it's totally
a matter of choice
number five finally a restaurant
speaking of living your life normally a
restaurant in Colorado called Castle
rocks CNC coffee and kitchen open for
Mother's Day and this is what it looked
like at that restaurant take a look at
some of the footage here people packed
in pretty tight I only play this to make
the point that you know when I look at
the surveys and I look at the polls I'm
told that people are still very afraid
and even if you open up all the stuff
people aren't gonna show up because
they're too afraid and I believe that
there are probably a large preponderance
of people who are afraid and aren't
gonna show up but I don't know if when
we look at the experience of states that
have started to reopen or some of these
companies that have defied the state
home orders or the lockdown orders and
have opened up anyway we look at that
anecdotally it seems like there are a
lot of people who are if you open up you
know they will come like Field of Dreams
if you open they will come it that seems
to be the case so this argument that it
doesn't matter there's no reason to open
because even if we do no one's gonna
show up that that's that's not what you
see in these kinds of videos that's not
what I have observed just in my own
experience we were out we were out for
Mother's Day happy Mother's Day by the
way to the ladies out there we were out
for Mother's Day yesterday and we went
to a you know kind of a park area and
there was there was an outdoor as a food
looking of a food concession stand and
and it was right next to the the beach
and there was a ton of people out you
know there were a lot of businesses that
were closed but people couldn't go to
those businesses but it seems to me
based on my experience that people are
doing as much as they can to live their
normal life and so I think if we open
things up businesses are going to find
that there is plenty of business out
there there are plenty of patrons out
there who would like to come and visit
ok let's go to your daily cancellation
we put it up put it off for long enough
but we have to get to this and before we
do that before we do that I'm stalling
not very well
right now we are offering you an
incredible deal for the first time ever
you can purchase the highly coveted
leftist tiers tumblr it leftist ears
tumblr it will actually be or leftist
tier actually will be shed for everyone
every one of the tumblr sets purchased
I'm botching this the whole point is
that you can buy a leftist ears tumblr
okay you don't have to actually become a
member you can buy daily wire members
get many amazing benefits including of
course the singular leftist ears tumblr
you also get an ad-free website
experience access to our live broadcast
and show library the full three hours of
the ben shapiro show access to the
mailbag and now exclusive election
insight up op eds from from ben shapiro
daily wire members also get to ask us
questions during backstage and our
all-access members also get to
participate in the all-access live but
the leftist tears tumblr now is not only
given to people in that category if you
are one of the peons who is not a daily
wired member how dare you well you can
at least buy it it's available for
purchase this is the first time we've
ever done something like this so you
really want to take advantage before
it's too late
alright well do better next time i
didn't get a lot sleep last night if you
can't tell I have no idea anything I've
said so far I have no idea what I've
said it's all black is I blacked out as
I say it so hopefully it went okay now
for your daily cancellation we are
canceling Kim Brooks of the New York
Times she finds herself on the
metaphorical chopping block for this
editorial in The Times this weekend just
in time for Mother's Day
the title is forget pancakes pay mothers
forget pancakes pay mothers why pancakes
anyway that's the weirdest false
dichotomy I've ever heard
I don't want pancakes pay mothers I mean
even if I agree that we should pay
mothers why can't we have pancakes - I
don't understand
one lesson from the pandemic childcare
is work and it should be compensated so
miss basically miss Brooks has found
herself because of the lockdowns
actually performing the full-time duties
of a mother apparently for the first
time and after a few weeks of that
experience she's decided that she needs
to be paid for it that's her revelation
that she needs to be getting paid the
this stuff so let's read a little bit
from this from this article it says
after just six days of sheltering in
place I found myself thinking about all
the women I'd taken for granted I
started with Griselda who cared for my
kids when they were babies a few hours
each week I thought about Beth and
Perrine and every babysitter and
cleaning lady I've ever used all the
women I'd paid to come into my home over
the past 13 years so that I could leave
it and do other things side note here I
think that every child should have a
nanny called Griselda or at least if
you're gonna get a nanny for your kid
she should be called Griselda even if
that's not her name you should give her
a new name goes out what you can do with
nanny so you can calm whatever you want
there the hired help okay says if
someone has had asked me why I paid
these women to do things that I could do
myself particularly when I made so
little money with the time they freed up
I'd say that it I did it because I
wanted to work because I needed to work
not just out of economic necessity but
also out of a need to feel like a human
being the implication here was that when
I did the childcare and housework in
cooking and laundry it was not work but
something else oh no that's not the
implication at all but we'll get to that
in a second now for the first time
everyone is doing the work we don't call
work when women do it we watched Jimmy
Fallon play with his daughters while
filming The Tonight Show and think maybe
it's work after all another side note if
you're having any revelations at all
about Parenthood from watching Jimmy
Fallon I don't know what to say aside
from I feel bad for your kids but a
little later on it says I came close to
it to applying to medical school but
instead I had it but she's going into
her background and blah blah blah so I
was gonna apply for medical school
instead I had a baby than another my
children's father made enough to support
us but not enough to provide for the
child care we need when I returned to
school or take a full-time job and so
throughout my 30s I found myself largely
occupied with keeping a home and raising
my children this worked despite bringing
joy and meaning to my life shared many
of the qualities of the menial jobs I'd
done before but there was one important
difference the work I've done as a
mother I've done for free now we get to
the really unshockable okay the part
that you saw coming a mile away
get ready for this you saw this come you
knew this was happening she says I've
been thinking about this a lot lately
because when the pandemic
exploded I happened to find myself in
the middle of a divorce I wouldn't
recommend this timing you know funny how
that happens right a woman who thinks
that she should be paid to perform the
basic duties of motherhood happens to
find herself in the middle of a divorce
it seems that this this has a tendency
to happen to selfish people does it just
happens not their fault it just happens
they're just walking along one day and
boom splat they fall into a divorce
never saw it coming like a puddle on the
sidewalk they fall into a puddle of
divorce oh no I look look where I happen
to find myself how did this occur I have
no idea because it couldn't possibly be
that their own attitude and approach and
their whole view of and approach to life
led them directly to this inevitable
conclusion could it no couldn't be that
okay well uh so alright we'll read a
little bit more this she says
and yet our entire economic system
hinges on the willingness of women to do
this work for free caretakers who work
outside the home are poorly paid but
those who care for their own kin in
their own homes aren't paid at all they
receive a wage of $0.00 no health
insurance no sick leave no paid time off
no 401k for a long time I tried not to
think about it one of the ways I was
able to not think about it was because I
could pay other women to lighten my load
for the time being those days are over
maybe that's for the best
in 2012 the Marxist feminist Sylvia
Sylvia Federici you're also that's this
is the other part of this you're not
surprised to hear that she's quoting
Marxist feminist published a collection
of essays says revolution at point zero
housework reproduction a feminist
struggle about a largely forgotten
movement the campaign for wages for
housework Federici writes to say that we
want wages for housework is the first
step toward refusing to do it it's what
makes invisible visible she says in
other words if garbage collectors and
grocery store workers and hedge fund
managers expect to be paid for the labor
why not those who create and sustain the
human race why can't we imagine some
form of universal basic caretaker income
to support the work of mother's or
Father's or other extended kin to do at
home okay yada yada
you get the idea so let's talk about
this for a minute
why shouldn't mothers get paid well the
first answer I'd give is that they do in
some form if a mother stays at home and
has a working husband then she gets by
then she gets then then she gets paid by
the husband's employer you know
indirectly not directly but the effect
is the same so I would never say that I
pay my wife to take care of our kids
because that would be demeaning as hell
and I'll get back to that in a minute
but all the money that I make goes into
a joint account and she has access to it
and can use it and does whenever she
wants so I don't think that's an issue
working mothers get paid by their
employers and most of the mothers who
neither work nor have working husbands
get paid by the welfare system so most
mothers are getting paid as far as I can
see second point what about the duties
of fatherhood
you know why are they always left out of
these discussions so my wife does more
cumulatively in terms of parenting
household duties because I'm working
during the day but when I'm not working
I'm on the scene I'm helping I'm doing
things so if we're paying mothers to be
mothers it seems only fair that we pay
fathers to be fathers yes my employer
pays me but my employer pays me to be an
employee when it comes to the stuff that
is specific to being a father no one's
paying me for that that's not fair
that's not fair someone has to pay me
why am I doing this otherwise it's a
paraphrase the article third point who
is going to make these payments the
grocery store clerk you see gets paid by
the grocery store simple enough he the
clerk accepts the conditional
responsibility of ringing up people's
food purchased you know the people's
food purchases for seven or eight hours
a day in exchange for that he gets X
amount of money he agrees to that going
in if he doesn't like the job he does
like to pay you can quit and go on
strike but the system makes sense
grocery store pays clerk with the money
they get from the customer so I as a
customer in helping to pay the clerk
salary why am i doing that because the
clerk is helping me and so it's a whole
system that makes a lot of sense people
it may not people may not always feel
that it's fair forever
involved but it's it's it's a it's a
sensible system we understand how that
works
who is supposed to be making these
payments to mothers well of course we
know the answer I am and you through our
taxes right that's what we're talking
about so this money is supposed to come
from the government which means it's
coming from me partially but but here's
the thing an excuse me if this sounds
harsh why should I pay you to raise your
own kids that's not a service you're
providing to me you check out my
groceries at the grocery store you're
providing me a service by raising your
own kids you're not providing me a
service why would I beg you for that why
would I pay you for that any more than I
would pay you to fix your own car and by
the way what about the husbands that
work on their their family car I mean
I'm not the handiest guy so I don't
really do that but whatever there are
plenty of husbands who do better men men
than me are we gonna pay them a
mechanic's salary no we don't why don't
we because they're doing it for
themselves
it's not a service they're providing to
society or to anybody they're just it's
something they're doing for their own
sake for the sake of their family and
what's the other option if the court the
clerk doesn't like what he's getting
paid he can quit he can go on strike is
that the other option as a parent you
can go on strike
quit leave your kids starving and dirty
and neglected no that's not an option if
you do that we'll haul your butt to jail
he'll go to jail for that you're not
gonna go to jail if you refuse to work
as a clerk you might get fired but
somebody in your house has to care for
your kids or you have to hire somebody
who will if you don't you go to jail why
again because it's your duty it's your
responsibility not conditionally not
contractually but naturally it is what
society expects you to do demands that
you do it is what your children need you
to do we don't pay people to do that
kind of thing that's really basic just
like we don't pay you to put on your own
pants in the morning
it's quite the opposite if you don't put
on your pants in the morning and go
outside then you might
then you might face some penalties for
that again why is it well for the
reasons that I've given but for another
reason too and see this is the strange
thing about feminists they tend to be
skeptical of capitalism but at the same
time they idolize it they make a
religion of it right all at once so
while being skeptical of it and
complaining about they also idolize it
and make a religion religion of it which
is the same thing they do of masculinity
by the way they hate masculinity they
denigrate masculinity
they also idolize masculinity and they
want nothing more than to be men but you
look at it here because these are people
who think that a kind of work must be
less valuable less important less
dignified if you aren't paid to do it
like somehow the act of making money of
profiting off of a thing imbues it with
dignity now I would say the opposite is
true I would say that the things we do
for free as it were the things that we
do because they are natural duties the
things we do out of love and service to
our family those are far more dignified
far more important and they exist in a
realm above and beyond the marketplace I
get paid for the duties I perform at my
job because it's merely a job I don't
get paid to go home and be a father
because that is my calling that's my
vocation that's my identity it is many
things but job is not one of them
there's a difference between work and a
job now all jobs involve work
theoretically speaking but not all work
is a job some work is above a job is
greater than job is transcends the label
of job and and that's the point and
that's why I say it's degrading you know
if I were to come home and you know my
wife has fed the kids for the day and
clean the house and done all that stuff
and I were to pull out my my wallet and
say a nice job here's a hundred bucks
but that would be incredibly demeaning
that's not that's people want
recognition and-and-and
the gratitude for the things they do and
we should give that to each other as
spouses and within the family but not in
the form of cold hard cash you know it's
just like most of the time Madhu for
love as I said are the things that we do
in in fulfillment of our natural duties
those are beyond the job and they are
beyond being paid for and and you you
can't quantify it anyway it's literally
priceless work there are a lot the
things you do at a job that's not
priceless we can put a price on that the
things you do for your kid and your
spouse those are prices can't put a
price on it and that's the point all
right so that's why in fact you know
because this is a distinction lost on
modern people generally especially
feminists I think that's why I'm gonna
cancel I'm just I was gonna cancel just
the author of this article I think
instead I'm gonna cancel all of modern
society which which I think probably
covers everything and maybe it's the
last cancellation we need to do because
I'm just modern societies cancel
although I'm gonna keep doing them
anyway cuz they're fine well leave it
there thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening have a great day
happy belated Mother's Day and Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there